what do you think happens when you die
as Bertrand Russell said I believe that
when I die I shall rot and nothing of my
ego shall remain that's it
yes yes nothing there's nothing else how
could it how could it be otherwise I
mean you you have a brain an evolved
brain which works by nerve impulses and
when that decays what could possibly be
left so you don't believe in for example
a spirit or a soul none of that is
that's all conditional entirely on a
link to a an actual cerebral yes if by a
spiritual Soul you mean something that
outlasts the brain that I do not believe
in it no really
well how could I well people have gone
through weird sort of outer body
near-death experiences where they
they've been pronounced dead for a few
minutes they always talk about almost
all of them talk about this weird
there's a tunnel a tunnel right at the
end yeah so I mean yeah it could be
couldn't it yes well read Susan
Blackmore on that